[Music]
after glenn younkin's shocking win in
virginia the left hasn't engaged in any
reflection whatsoever instead they're
accusing virginia voters the people who
just elected an african-american
lieutenant governor of being racists
and when he pushes talking points that
are meant to
flirt with and stoke white backlash he
does so in a coded way with dog whistles
about education the racial animus
that is teeming
um with the dog whistle messaging racial
language and
dog whistles quite frankly some of it
was dog whistle yeah right some of it
was
uh dog whistle racism horrible racist uh
dog whistles from the gop dog whistling
on education i think all the crt stuff
is trumped up dog whistling what rose to
sort of the national conversation
was the dog whistle
notice they keep referring to dog
whistles but they never even say what
they're talking about
shelby steals the writer of the
documentary what killed michael brown
and he joins us with reaction all right
so shelby why won't they define and
defend exactly what crt is
because they have no way to do it and
they know that it's
it
is in opposition to the america's
commitment to a racial harmony that's
gone on now for 60 70 years
the civil rights movement the civil
rights victories
uh equality in the sense of as as
individuals
all of that this that that classic
liberalism
they see as uh
as
infringing on their power if they can
suspend that liberalism
uh then they have the power to
dictate what goes on you saw terry
mcauliffe talking about
one high school that had 80 percent
white teachers we needed to change that
we needed to go in
disregard their rights
and cut that down to 50 percent uh well
it's that kind of cold inhuman
calculation as a pretext for racial
harmony
uh that's ex that is extremely
destructive
uh and uh this
the reaction to it that we've seen in in
this uh this current election
is by my life it's a wonderful thing
it's it's a
it's a return to the classic view of
racial harmony based on on
our connection and appreciation of each
other as individuals
rather than strictly members of a race
members of a nationality and ethnicity
and so forth so these are all very
divisive
uh ways of thinking
such a brilliant point that you made
martin luther king the civil rights
movement that was all about a colorblind
society that was about judging people
not by the color of their skin but by
the content of their character and this
is against
everything that that was about
this is about you're not born equal
people are born racist people are born
oppressed
and as you said that
framework gives the left a pretext to
seize power
and then re-engineer society move people
up pull people down rework the entire
system
and it just takes away
what is in our founding document that
all men are created equal
absolutely that's uh that's burdensome
as far as they're concerned
they they truly are offended by
by that by this idea that we're as it
should be treated as individuals
uh they have
over the last since since the 60s
gained enormous power the power of the
american left really is grounded in race
uh in the idea of america as a
victimizing oppressive nation
and that they then cast themselves as
our redeemers
and they're going to lift us out of this
shame
and as such
uh they need the power to socially
engineer without worrying about whether
they're
they're being civilized or not you're
right they're preying on white guilt and
i think for the first time in a long
time the race card backfired didn't work
thank god for that shelby steele thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else